ya sabemos cómo nombrar aldehídos y
cetonas pero lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es ver un mecanismo con el cual se
puede formar una aceptan a digamos que
tenemos un benceno y en la primera parte
de la reacción este benceno simplemente
va a estar por ahí
entonces tenemos un benceno y tenemos un
cloruro de hace tilos o también llamado
cloruro de etanol lo que es un grupo
carbón hilo con un grupo metilo por aquí
ch3 y un átomo de cloro ok se parece
muchísimo a los aldehídos ya las zonas
pero aquí en lugar de tener una cadena
de carbonos o un hidrógeno tenemos un
claro ok entonces este es un ácido
clorhídrico o cloruro de etanol o
cloruro cloruro
hace
y lo íbamos a tener como catalizador al
cloruro de aluminio y eso de que sea un
catalizador lo que significa es que no
se transforma en la reacción si
interactúa con las otras moléculas pero
entra a la reacción y sale de la
reacción exactamente como la misma
molécula aunque en medio de la reacción
si cambie y por algunos momentos no sea
la misma molécula entonces tenemos como
catalizador al cloruro de aluminio que
es un aluminio con
un cloro dos claros y tres claros ahora
el primer paso de este mecanismo de
reacción es convertir al cloruro de
acetil o en un electro feedlots super
fuerte aunque los electro filos son
moléculas que son súper buenas robándose
los electrones de otras moléculas y
tenemos que transformar a este cloruro
de acetil o en un electro filo tan bueno
que pueda romper la aro matiz y that del
benceno y enlazarse con el benceno ok el
mecanismo es básicamente el mismo
mecanismo de sustitución electro física
aromática nada más que aquí lo que se va
a agregar al benceno es un grupo así lo
cree este grupo de aquí es un grupo
asilo y en esta reacción vamos a
agregarle este grupo asilo al benceno
hoy vamos a asilar el benceno y por eso
esta reacción se llama oscilación de
frío del kraft
y es una reacción muy similar a la
sustitución electro física aromática
pero buena suficiente de ver qué es lo
que va a pasar vamos a ver como sucede
todo aquí en este cloruro de aluminio
resulta que esté aluminio es pobre en
electrones porque a ver ahora vamos a
necesitar la tabla periódica
como podemos ver aquí el cloro es super
electro negativo y el aluminio aunque
está en la misma fila está mucho más a
la izquierda que el cloro entonces el
cloro es mucho más electro negativo que
el aluminio por lo que cada uno de estos
claros va a estar abrazando muchísimo a
los dos electrones que forman cada uno
de estos enlaces y entonces el aluminio
pasa mucho menos tiempo con cada uno de
sus tres electrones de valencia por lo
que tiene una carga parcial positiva y
bueno cada uno de estos claros tiene una
carga parcial negativa entonces este
aluminio quiere tener más electrones
porque tiene la carga parcial positiva
pero además como podemos ver en la tabla
periódica el aluminio está en el grupo 1
2 3 lo cual significa que tiene
únicamente 3 electrones de valencia
estos 3 electrones de aquí
a todos los átomos les gusta pretender
que tienen más electrones de los que
tienen y si están haciendo un enlace con
otro átomo cada uno de los átomos puede
pretender que tiene los dos electrones
del enlace aunque este electrón en
realidad pertenece al cloro entonces el
aluminio está pretendiendo que tiene
todos estos electrones de los claros
pero aún así pretendiendo que tiene los
electrones de los claros únicamente
tiene 6 electrones así es que a este
aluminio realmente le gustaría tener más
electrones para acercarse a ese número
mágico de 8 electrones y bueno por acá
tenemos otro átomo de cloro que ya vimos
que es súper electro negativo en la
tabla periódica entonces este cloro está
abrazando muy fuertemente a este
electrón lo cual lo hace más susceptible
de ser robado por este aluminio entonces
lo que pasa es que este aluminio se va a
quedar con este electrón y entonces se
va a formar un enlace
el aluminio y el cloro haciendo el
enlace con estos dos electrones y
entonces ahora como se ven todas las
cosas pues tenemos por aquí el aluminio
con sus 3
claros
pero ahora se acaba de quedar con este
nuevo electrón el electrón azul y está
formando un enlace con el átomo de cloro
que antes estaba en el cloruro de acetil
o con este cloro por lo que ahora el
aluminio tiene una carga negativa y las
moléculas que tienen cargas negativas no
suelen ser muy estables pero como
tenemos 4 cloro y los claros son super
electro negativos entonces la verdad es
que estos cuatro claros se están
quedando con una muy buena parte de la
carga negativa por estar abrazando tanto
a los electrones del aluminio y además
el aluminio ahora puede pretender que
tiene 8 electrones porque los átomos
pueden pretender que tienen los dos
electrones de sus enlaces covalentes
pero ahora qué pasa con el cloruro de
acetil y bueno lo voy a dibujar por aquí
pero recuerda que todo esto de aquí es
como el segundo paso de la reacción
aquí estamos pasando del primer paso al
segundo paso
el cloruro de acetil o acaba de perder
un átomo de cloro y entonces es un grupo
carbón y lo con ch3 y como perdió un
electrón ahora tiene una carga positiva
ahora esta molécula no es muy estable de
hecho es muy reactiva es un excelente
electro filo y es buenísimo quitándole
electrones a otras moléculas pero si
puede existir cierta cantidad de tiempo
porque esta molécula es estabilizada por
resonancia ok a ver a qué me refiero con
eso pues tenemos aquí al oxígeno y no le
había dibujado sus dos pares de
electrones por aquí y por acá y lo que
sucede es que este carbono tiene una
carga positiva y por aquí este oxígeno
tiene estos dos pares de electrones que
se pueden sentir muy atraídos por la
carga positiva del carbono entonces en
algún punto uno de ellos puede ir a
quedarse con el carbono y así obtenemos
la
otra forma de esta molécula en
resonancia que aquí acabo de dibujar tal
cual lo que teníamos aquí está un par de
electrones del oxígeno pero en esta
estructura este electrón del oxígeno fue
a dar al carbono está por aquí el otro
electrón de este par de electrones se
queda con el oxígeno y entonces se forma
otro enlace entre el oxígeno y el
carbono ahora este carbono recibió un
electrón por lo cual ya no tiene una
carga positiva pero este oxígeno perdió
uno de sus electrones por lo que ahora
tiene una carga positiva y bueno esta
molécula tampoco es muy estable no es
como que uno se encuentre estas
moléculas en cualquier momento pero si
pueden existir un intervalo de tiempo en
lo que reaccionan con el benceno pero
bueno aquí ya hice un relajo porque no
es como que tengamos estas dos moléculas
siempre tenemos una o la otra es una
misma molécula estabilizada por la
resonancia y
as esto de aquí es el primer paso de la
reacción y aquí ya estamos en el segundo
paso de la redacción y ahora si se
involucra el benceno en la reacción así
es que vamos a hacer que aparezca por
aquí pero le vamos a dibujar uno de sus
hidrógenos no vamos a dibujar el resto
de sus hidrógenos porque sería demasiado
relajo ahora
el chiste es que esta molécula de aquí
es un excelente electro filo porque
necesita obtener un electrón a como ver
lugar y aunque el benceno sea muy
estable por la resonancia de aromática
si llegara este electro filo a golpear a
este benceno de la forma adecuada este
grupo así lo se va a quedar con uno de
los electrones del anillo vencen y ccoo
y entonces este electrón va a dar al
carbono y con este par de electrones se
forma un enlace entre el grupo asilo y
el anillo vencen y ccoo y entonces ahora
que tenemos
voy a seguir la reacción por acá
entonces vamos al tercer paso de la
reacción y entonces tenemos un anillo
benz en icod que acaba de perder uno de
sus electrones lo vamos a hacer aparecer
por aquí
un hidrógeno y ahora este par de
electrones este electrón se queda por
aquí y el otro electrón el electrón azul
ahora pertenece al grupo así lo y bueno
voy a voltear este grupo así lo para que
quede el grupo metilo del lado derecho y
entonces tenemos por aquí el carbono con
el electrón azul que le acaba de robar
al anillo vencen y ccoo y por lo tanto
ya no tiene una carga positiva con
el oxígeno y el grupo metilo pero por
otro lado este carbono perdió a uno de
sus electrones por lo que ahora tiene
una carga positiva ahora si recuerdas
decíamos que el cloruro de aluminio era
solo un catalizador así es que no se va
a quedar con 4 cloro tiene que tener
únicamente tres claros al final de la
reacción entonces vamos a copiarlo y
pegarlo por aquí ahora como te puedes
imaginar este anillo quiere volver a ser
aromático y volver a tener resonancia
aromática y para eso necesita este
electrón de aquí porque para que se
forme un doble enlace entre estos dos
carbonos y por otro lado este aluminio
tiene una carga negativa les sobra uno
de estos electrones y entonces si el
aluminio pasa muy cerca de este
hidrógeno lo que va a hacer es regalarle
este electrón azul
el núcleo del hidrógeno que por cierto
es simplemente un protón y al mismo
tiempo el electrón del hidrógeno se va a
ir con este carbono y entonces ahora qué
es lo que nos queda pues lo que tenemos
es al anillo vencen y ccoo completo que
vamos a hacer aparecer por aquí solo que
ahora este enlace doble está formado con
este electrón que antes pertenecía al
hidrógeno ok
los electrones de este enlace doble son
los electrones de este enlace de aquí y
el electrón azul que antes formaba este
doble enlace ahora pertenece al carbono
del grupo así lo ok con su doble enlace
con un oxígeno y su grupo metilo
entonces reemplazamos a un hidrógeno del
benceno por un grupo asilo y por otro
lado el cloruro de aluminio aquí lo
tenemos
con tres claros y ya no tiene carga
negativa porque ella le dio uno de sus
electrones con todo y un átomo de cloro
al núcleo del hidrógeno ok
este anio no volvió a ser simplemente
cloruro de aluminio con toda su
deficiencia de electrones y sus ganas de
quedarse con un electrón del cloruro de
acetil o lo que entró a la reacción como
un simple cloruro de aluminio y está
saliendo de ella tal cual como entró
como un cloruro de aluminio mientras que
el benceno y el cloruro de acetil o
ahora están formando un acetona ok
acabamos de asilar al benceno y por eso
esta reacción se llama oscilación
si la
acción
d
friedel craft
él
que se llama oscilación porque acabamos
de asilar al benceno y de fría del craft
porque ellos fueron los que descubrieron
esta reacción y hay algo muy curioso
acerca de craft resulta que nunca
terminó su doctorado pero sí hizo varios
descubrimientos como este mecanismo de
afiliación y aunque nunca se título de
doctorado por todos sus grandes logros y
por ser una persona muy trabajadora e
inteligente en algún punto hasta fue
presidente del mighty pero bueno el
chiste en este vídeo es que acabamos de
formar una zona llamada aceptó fe no la
aceptó
en onna y bueno de hecho esta molécula
ya la habíamos visto en el primer vídeo
acerca de cetonas aunque se llama hace
toffee nona y listo